تشارك في دراسه تجريها جامعه ستانفورد
الامريكيه وكانت بنت شختت قبل سنوات بمرض
التنكس العصبي ما اثر في قدرتها على
الكلام يامل العلماء امكانيه تحسين حياه
المرضى قبل ان يصلوا الى هذه المرحله من
خلال منحهم القدره على التواصل
الاشارات من خلايا الدماغ الفرديه وترسل
عبر جهاز من الفولاذ المقاوم للصدا يوضع
على جمجمه المريض ويخرج من خلال فروه
الراس ثم تضخم الاشارات المنتجه وتنقل الى
خارج الجمجمه ببرمجيه التعليم الالي
وتعالج بواسطه خوارزميه وبعد ذلك يمكن فك
تشفير النشاط الدماغي وتحويله الى كلمات
على شاشه الحاسوب وذلك عبر الصوت من اجل
الحصول على اشارات لفك شفرتها الى لغه زرع
فريق ستانفرد اقطابا كهربائيه صغيره تخترق
دماغها
الكلام باستخدام وحدات صوتيه او ما يسمى
في اللسانيات الفونيم والتي تشكل الكلمات
يقول العلماء انهم ياملون زياده عدد
الكلمات التي يمكن لشخص ان يولدها
لقد تمكنا من فك رموز 125 الف كلمه من
المفردات وهي لغه انجليزيه عامه مع معدل
خطا يصل الى 24% تقريبا تمكنا من فك شفره
مفردات مكونه من 50 كلمه انها مفردات
مفيده يمكن لشخص مصاب بالشلل الشديد
استخدامها لايصال الاحتياجات الاساسيه هذه
المراه وتدعى ان تشارك في دراسه منفصله
اجراها باحثون من جامعه كاليفورنيا في سان
فرانسيسكو ويقول الباحثون ان انت تعاني
شللا نصفيا منذ اصابتها بنزف في جذع
الدماغ ولم تتمكن من التحدث لمده 17 عاما
في جذع الدماغ دائما ولكنها ليست تنكسيه
ما يعني ان اشارتي ان لن تقل وتضعف بمرور
الوقت تعمل هذه التقنيه بطريقه مشابهه
لدراسه جامعه ستانفورد لكنها لا تستخدم
الاقطار الكهربائيه التي تخترق الدماغ
يضعوا هذا الفريق شبكه كهربائيه تحت
الجمجمه لذلك يتطلب الامر عمليه جراحيه
لكن الجهاز يوضع فهو الدماغ وحقق هذا
الجهاز اداء مماثلا تقريبا لما حققه نظام
فريق جامعه ستانفورد اذا ارتفع معدل
المحادثه الى 28 كلمه في الدقيقه اي اسرع
بخمس مرات مما كان عليه الوضع في السابق
يقول الفريق ان هدفهم الان انتاج نسخه
لاسلكيه من الجهاز قد تكون لها اثار عميقه
على استقلاليه المرضى
وتفاعلاتهم الاجتماع يه